this was the moment that the left has
been hoping for that we
were told uh you know was gonna happen
after the election it never happened
uh and these guys got out of control
it is also true uh that as we heard with
the black lives matter protests you know
we heard
for the riots the race riots that did
a hundred thousand times more
damage than happened as a physical
matter and as a
life matter than happened on january 6
the rolling riots that we saw over the
summer through the fall
that are now being completely rewritten
out of history by the mainstream media
not that they acknowledged them at all
at the time but now they're being
completely erased
those were far more destructive in terms
of property damage and
damage to government property than
anything that happened on january
6th
all right so let's let's shift to where
you were going there about the capitol
hill protest are you telling me heather
mcdonald
that that man with the horns and the
face paint
that that guy was not the leader of a
giant coup they weren't going to take
over the entire government that day
because if you watch cnn jake tapper
there was an insurrection these people
were going to take over all of our
governmental institutions
well i am not going to defend them for
an instant and i
i cannot state enough uh that
as a a prerequisite probably
to everything i'm saying i'm not
justifying them i'm not making an
apology for them
but this was a one-off you know this was
the moment
that the left has been hoping for that
we were told
uh you know was going to happen after
the election it never happened
uh and these guys got out of control
it is also true uh that as we heard with
the black lives matter protest you know
we heard
for the riots the race riots that did
a hundred thousand times more
damage than happened as a physical
matter
and as a life matter than happened on
january six
the rolling riots that we saw over the
summer
through the fall that are now being
completely
rewritten out of history by the
mainstream media not that they
acknowledged them
at all at the time but now they're being
completely erased
those were far more destructive in terms
of property damage
and damage to government property than
anything that happened on january 6th
i simply do not believe that what
happened then represents
an ongoing terror threat
these people are disorganized they're
losers they got out of control and
they have been in the grips of what i
would say
uh is a delusion which is the idea that
the
election was systematically rigged
uh you know i but what i you know
one's attitude towards what went on on
january 6 to a certain extent
will be influenced by whether you
believe the rigging narrative
they believe it and and if the election
was systemically rigged
that is very serious business that
undermines the legitimacy
of our government and justifies
something it doesn't justify violence
but it justifies something
uh and and so that that makes this whole
uh debate about what went on
complicated because there's a factual
dispute at the heart of of both sides
from a legal perspective um do you think
trump was inciting them when he was
saying i mean he did repeatedly say
peaceful but it's
but i think what a lot of people are
saying is well what did he think was
going to happen when
when they got there i mean actually i
think had things not gotten out of hand
ted cruz would have issued a you know a
statement that day
saying you know i object to this or that
and rand paul would have done the same
the day would have finished up and then
and then actually what i think what
happened was people would have realized
it was over i think that's where it was
all heading
yeah i'm not an expert on the law of
incitement so
i'm not i don't know what the legal
standards are but
it's complicated i mean he's he's got
statements and again
this is what's difficult is how you view
what he said does depend
on what your view is of the underlying
claim of rigging
you can't get around that if you think
the rigging idea was
preposterous as i do then
you know for him to go and say you know
take back the capital
uh sounds possibly
too provocative but if it's right if
if he really was the rightful winner
and the election was stolen from him
uh then his rhetoric
looks simply factual you know i want to
stop you there for a second because it's
interesting because even though you're
really just talking about sort of the
sort of psychological makeup of some of
the people and the behaviors related to
the information that we all get
i know it's very possible that youtube
is going to take this video down because
we're really not even supposed to talk
about this even though
you're fully saying that you believe
that it that the election was
legitimate but that's just the sort of
information war that we're in related to
all of this
you know the question dave is
what is this country going to look like
in five years or three years
this this censorship is happening so
quickly
i mean my mind is just blown by it i
don't know
what one can do and and the other thing
that worries me
and this comes out of the academy again
up to now
federal judges have been pretty good in
striking down
free speech limitations on college
campuses which
you know they they the things that get
appeal to them tend to be the
speech codes which are by now are sort
of archaic and
a trivial problem compared to the much
broader
campus climate of censorship but the
judges have been pretty good on first
amendment
but what are future judges going to be
like
they're they're the product of this
academy as well and during the brett
kavanaugh hearings you had
students from the harvard and yale law
schools
protesting saying belief survivors you
know
trying to torpedo the kavanaugh
nomination
the belief survivors mantra that is the
absolute central
plank of feminism today is completely
antithetical to
due process it is the rejection of the
presumption of innocence
the hate speech conceit that we're
seeing now
weaponized in the world at large to do
censorship when you have
members of the press saying we should
censor fox news we should de-platform
everybody
because hate speeches behavior speech
destroys people's lives as you pointed
out hate speech is not a
constitutionally protected
or you know recognized category the
judges
the judges that we are entrusting with
our constitution
are the products of the academy that is
giving us these
these poisonous ideas so i don't know
how much longer we can count on
america the way we know it to have been
it's so
i mean it's it's scary what you're
saying there but i think what i hear
from a lot of conservatives
is oh the courts are the sort of last
line on this that maybe trump got enough
judges in
for now because he did get a lot of i
mean with something like 400 judges if
i'm not mistaken he got a ton of judges
in
that that's the last line but but i
think you're right it's also that
they're a function of the culture and
everything else and the more we target
individual people and then they get
scared and they don't want to be called
a racist
on top of the fact that they themselves
may have been indoctrinated
at at some level it's a it's a scary
stew
let me shift to something that you might
find a little more uh inspiring then i
was
at uh the turning point usa student
action summit uh right before christmas
and uh we've talked about this before
but you're you're a non-religious
conservative which sometimes people find
to be an oxymoron i do not and we've had
a couple interesting chats about it
but at turning point they had a
conservative secular
coalition there it was the first time
this group had been invited
and there was there were a lot of them
there i didn't interview with them
and as i was talking i think i brought
you up in the interview but i see
something really nice
happening there that there suddenly is
this sort of burst
of secular conservatism uh and i thought
you might just like to hear that
interesting no i was unaware of that
that's fantastic it doesn't necessarily
change a lot of the other rhetoric that
comes out of
a lot of conservative talk show hosts
but but
you know again if we if we really
believe in being inclusive
uh that's that's a good thing yeah that
seemed to be the overriding idea so sort
of going back a little bit to the
to the censorship part of this has any
of the big tech censorship the way
they're trying to kick fox off the air
their way the way they're trying to get
rid of youtubers or saying that you
can't talk about any of these things
has any of that pushed your free market
principles
to the breaking point that seems to be a
new place that libertarians and
conservatives
are fighting at the moment like oh we
should have used the power of the
government when we had trump to break up
the
tech monopolies or do you fully believe
in the free market or
some combination thereof
yeah this again is not my expertise
and i'm the the big thing
that i find so astounding with the the
members of the liberal elites that are
calling now from censorship
is their childlike inability to think in
terms of principles
they think that they will always have
power and that therefore they can
establish the precedent of uh
shutting down speech that will never be
used against them
and you think my god you know an adult
is supposed to be able to abstract from
his own situation to think in terms
of neutral principles and i used to go
around to college campuses
and and say to the the lefty students
who were yes also
screaming and and you know having heart
attacks at my very presence there say
do you want this power of censorship
in the hands of donald trump and
ironically trump
did not try to censor people but now you
have
you know max boot and washington post
writers and
heads of columbia journalism school
saying well you know this free speech
thing is not really so great we got to
get rid of it
but what if we get trump 2024 god forbid
or somebody else it's going to use it
against you and i would so i would say
the same thing
uh with taking on the the big tech
companies
that they are private and so
i i'm i'm worried about any kind of
precedent that would be used for
government
to go after a private entity because we
may think we're doing it
in a for a good cause now but
the tables can always turn if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell